The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All right, well,
I guess I may as well start.
I don't know if anybody
else is going to come.
So I wanted to finish up
by talking a little bit
about the biomimicking.
And some of these examples,
you've seen before.
But I just thought I'd
put them all together,
and we could look at
them as one thing.
So if you remember,
when we talked
about wood, one of the
things that I showed
you was that people have
taken wood and pyrolized it.
So they get a carbon
template of the wood cells.
And then they infiltrate
that with silicon carbide--
or, with a silicon
vapor infiltration.
And they make a silicon
carbide ceramic.
So they can get a
replica of the structure.
So sometimes when people
say "biomimicking,"
some people think of it
as replicating something.
But it doesn't have to be
just replicating something.
It can be also just
some design inspired
by the biological material.
But this thing
really is a replica.
And this was another
version where
there was the-- they took
the silicon carbide material
and then infiltrated
that with liquid silicon
to get a fiber-reinforced
material, really.
So there was the wood
composites we talked about.
Jennifer Lewis's
group up at Harvard
is doing 3-D printing
of honeycombs.
And one of the things
they've been interested in
is not just printing
of the pure resin,
but having a
fiber-reinforced resin.
And the first thing
they did was they
made these honeycombs like this.
And they had small
silicon carbon fibers--
or, were they silicon carbide?
Maybe it was carbon
fibers-- in the ink.
And so they would just-- if
the ink was being laid down,
the fibers would just line up
in the direction of the ink.
And so the fibers tended to be
in the plane of the honeycomb.
And if you think of
things like wood,
you want the fibers to
normal to that plane.
And more recently,
they've-- hello.
Oh, hello.
Oh, look.
Oh, look, almost
everybody is here.
So more recently, they've
got a technology now
where they're
rotating the nozzle
as they print the honeycomb.
And as they rotate
the nozzle, they
get some change in the
orientation of the fiber.
So they're beginning to
be able to make honeycombs
that are fiber-reinforced.
And they can get the fibers
aligned with the prism
axis of the honeycomb,
which is more or less what
the wood does.
So I wasn't going to write
anything on the board today.
I was just going to go
over some of the slides
and do the review.
So they're beginning
to make honeycombs
that have the same sort of
structure on the cell wall
level, or at least
a similar structure,
as to what the wood
composites have.
So that's another example there.
This is just another close-up
of their fiber-reinforced walls
in honeycomb specimens.
We talked about trabecular bone,
and we talked about the fact
that people are starting
to look at using
foamed metals as coatings
on orthopedic implants.
And there's been some
interest in looking
at using foamed metals for more
permanent parts of the body,
more permanent bone parts,
things like vertebral cages,
stuff like that.
And so this is just
an example here,
with the trabecular
bone on the left
and the tantalum
foam that's made
by replicating an open-celled
polyurethane foam on the right.
And you can see the similarity
in the structures of those two
things there.
Then we talked about tissue
engineering scaffolds.
And if you remember, these two
scaffolds here on the bottom
were made from pig heart tissue.
And they're made by just
removing all the cells.
So that actually is the
natural extracellular matrix.
And then, these other
structures up here, these
were all engineered tissue
engineering scaffolds that
are made in a synthetic way.
And the idea is to try to
mimic the extracellular
matrix in the body.
So you can see the
similarities there.
And then more recently, we were
talking about sandwich panels.
So this is the example from
the helicopter rotor blade.
That's from an aircraft
flooring panel.
And this was the Irish leaf,
and these were the bird skulls.
So the same sort of
idea, that there's
these engineering lightweight
structures, and there's
also similar things in nature.
And then, I think, last time, we
also were talking about palms.
And the palm stems had
density gradients in them.
And one of the
things we showed was
that by having that
density gradient,
the stress distribution across,
say, the radius of the palm
was almost matched by the
strength distribution.
So it was a very efficient
way to use the material.
And at MIT, that was a
student in architecture
who was looking at doing this
with concretes with aerated
or foam concretes and making
a radial density distribution.
So he made beams.
He made columns.
He made different
kinds of things.
With the concrete, there's a
little bit of a limitation,
because the concrete is
much stronger in compression
than it is in tension.
So if you had a beam
loaded in tension
or a concrete column
that might buckle,
you'd still have to have some
reinforcing bars in there
to take the tensile loads.
And one thing I think I
didn't really talk about
was animal quills and other
sorts of plants stems.
And many of these
have a structure
that's made up of
a cylindrical shell
with a foam or a honeycomb core.
So here are some
examples in nature.
If you look at
grass stems, there's
a dense layer on the
outside, and then
a foamy layer on the
inside, and then just
a hollow layer in the middle.
And if you look at
porcupine quills--
this is a porcupine quill--
these are made of keratin.
They're like modified hairs.
So it has a dense
layer on the outside,
and then this foamy
stuff on the inside.
This is a hedgehog spine here.
And again, you can see there's
a dense layer on the outside
and these ribs on the inside.
And this is the toucan beak--
you know, the toucans that
live in Central America.
And the beak has a foam core.
Again, they're
keratin structures,
and yet the outside is solid.
But the inside has
a foamy structure.
And Mark Myers did a
paper on this a while ago.
So we got interested
in these structures
that have a solid
shell on the outside
but a foamy thing on the inside.
And we wondered if there was
a mechanical reason for that.
And you can show that,
at least in some of them,
if, say, you have
a grass stem-- it's
really common in plant stems.
Do I have some more plant stems?
Yeah, here we go.
Here's a milkweed stem.
So it's got these dense fibers
with this foamy core here.
And blue jay feathers--
feathers have this as well.
So they have an outside layer
on the quill that's solid,
and then an inside
layer that's foamy.
If you look at things like plant
stems, they blow in the wind.
And you can look at the
buckling resistance of the stem.
And because there's this
shell with the foam-like core,
it's not just the overall
buckling of the whole thing.
You can get that local
face-wrinkling mode again.
So the outer shell can wrinkle.
And you can show that
having a foam-like core
helps prevent that wrinkling
from happening, the same as
with the sandwich panel.
You remember we talked
about the face wrinkling
on the sandwich panel?
Well, on these
stems, you can get
wrinkling of the outer shell.
And the foam helps prevent
that from happening.
And you can show that
you can actually--
for the same buckling
load, you can reduce
the weight of the plant stem,
or the bird feather quill,
or whatever by having
that foamy core.
So people have
looked at this too.
And there's a group
in Germany who
had looked at the idea of
mimicking the horsetail stem.
So this is a plant stem
here, the horsetail plant.
And they made something they
called a technical plant
stem, where they made
this structure here.
And they made it out of
fiber-reinforced composites.
And you can see,
the little holes
here represent those holes
there, in the plant stem.
So the idea was to
try to get something
that was good at
resisting the buckling,
but at a lower weight.
And they were doing that
with this thing here.
And there was a group in Japan
that did a similar thing.
They used-- I think
they took a copper tube,
and then they took
copper and aluminum wires
and filled the copper
tube with the wires.
They extruded that.
And then they melted out the
aluminum, which, I think,
also helped to soften and
make the copper bond together.
And they got these
structures here.
And you can see,
that's similar to some
of the plant stems as well.
So these are all examples
of cellular structures
that have-- mechanically
efficient structures.
They're lightweight, and they're
strong, and they're stiff.
And these natural structures
have been mimicked
in engineering applications.
So that's really all I
wanted to talk about today.
But I think we wanted to use the
rest of the class as a review.
So I haven't made a one-hour
summary of the last six weeks,
because that's not
really possible.
So I thought I would
just answer questions.
If you have questions,
I'll try and answer them.
So for the test-- so,
the test is on Wednesday.
You can bring one 8
and 1/2 by 11 sheet.
I wasn't going to give you
all those honeycomb and foam
equations, partly because-- the
only thing I would really want
you know is open-cell foams.
And I was hoping,
by now, that you
might have registered
those equations somewhere
in your brain.
So I'm not going to ask you
for-- some equations are
obscure.
I might ask you--
expect you to know
what the Young's modulus
of an open-celled foam
is by now, or the axial modulus
of a honeycomb or something.
But I don't think I'm
going to ask you anything
like, calculate air pressure
contributions to the modulus
of the closed-cell foam.
I don't think we're going
to do that on this test.
So I think you should know what
the modulus of a-- the Young's
modulus of an open-celled
foam is, the shear
modulus of a foam,
because you need
that for the sandwich panels.
But you don't need reams and
reams of those equations,
so I wasn't going to
give you those this time.
OK?
So Jenny, did you have-- so
I finished the biomimicking
thing.
We're just going to do a review.
I don't know if you want to
stay or if you want to go.
You want to stay?
Well, whatever.
So do you have questions, Jenny?
AUDIENCE: I do.
I just wanted to have question 4
from the last pset reexplained.
Because I know that
you explained it to
in office hours, and I know
that the solutions are online,
and I looked at them.
I'm still confused.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
So, you're going to have to
remind me what problem 4 is,
because I don't remember.
AUDIENCE: Question 4 says,
polymethacrylate foam
at solid strength of 3.0-- or,
solid Young's modulus, rather,
of 3.0-- gigapascals
is being considered
for the energy absorption
layer in a bicycle helmet.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
I'll tell you what, I think I
have it on my little disk here.
Maybe that's easier,
because then I can read it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, let me just
see if that's going to come up.
There it is.
OK.
So this one here about
the foam, about the--
AUDIENCE: The one
with the graphs.
LORNA GIBSON:
--energy absorption?
AUDIENCE: I'm just a little
bit confused by the graphs.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
Let me see if I can
make this bigger.
Hang on a sec, my
computer's thinking.
OK.
And I think I gave you-- right,
I gave you this graph here.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
So can you read
what I've got here,
or is that-- should
I make it bigger?
AUDIENCE: I can't really
read it, [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Does that help?
OK.
So I have to admit, when
I put this together,
somebody-- I can't remember
who it was-- told me
you thought it was
overconstrained.
And it turned out it
was overconstrained.
And then I said,
forget the thickness.
Forget that I've given
you the thickness, right?
So disregard the thickness.
AUDIENCE: No, the velocity.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh,
speed-- the speed?
The speed-- all
right, OK, the speed.
No, I don't want to register.
OK.
So from what I gave you, you can
figure out the normalized peak
stress, right?
So you can get-- so if
I do this, is this good?
You can see what
I'm pointing at?
So you can get, the peak
stress is just the mass times
the acceleration over the area--
are we good with that-- divided
by Es, which I gave you.
So I think most people probably
got the peak stress here.
And then, because
I had given you
the velocity and
the thickness, I
was thinking you could
calculate the strain rate.
But if I don't give
you the velocity,
say we're not calculating the
strain rate at this point here,
OK?
So here, we're--
did I put this--
I don't know if I have the
graph on this solution.
There we go.
So this point here is the
2.5 times 10 to the minus 4
for the peak stress.
And if you're not
given the velocity,
I think what I thought you would
do then would be just assume
a velocity.
And then you can
check it at the end.
So since I had given
you this velocity of 12,
let's just say that's
what we assumed.
OK?
So then you get a strain
rate of 480 per second.
So let's just say we
assumed that velocity.
Then we could scoot
back over here.
So we know we're on this line
here for the sigma p over Es.
And we want to be up towards the
top of these different strain
rates.
So if you look at the
strain rates, see,
the very last one at the
top is 1,000 per second,
and the next one's
100 per second.
So we're halfway
in between those.
And they're so close
together, you can't really
read the difference.
But we're up here somewhere.
So then we read off
a w over Es for that.
OK?
Are we good?
Then, if we know
the w over Es, this
is the number, here,
that I read off.
You know what the Es
is, so you can get w.
If you can get w, w is in
joules per cubic meter.
It's in energy per unit volume.
But you know the area, and
you know the thickness.
So you can get the
energy in joules.
And then-- oh, did I-- I
must have rubbed that off.
Didn't have it on this version.
The version in my
notebook, I think,
calculated what
the velocity would
be that corresponds to this.
And I think it turned out
to be 8 meters per second
or something.
So I had assumed 12, and I
think it worked out to 8.
And on those log log
graphs, whether or not
it's a strain rate of
480, or a little bit less,
or a little bit more, you
can't read the difference
on these things.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain how this graph
relates to the other graphs
from lecture that were simpler?
Because we had ones that
were all density, and ones
that were all the
same strain rate.
And I guess I'm
just confused why.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, OK.
Hang on.
So let me see if
I can-- hang on.
No, I think I know
what you mean.
Let me see.
I want to pull up
the lecture notes.
I think I'm finding
the right thing.
Here we are.
So in the lecture
notes, there was
a thing that looked like this.
Is that what you're
talking about?
Yeah.
So the top set are the
stress strain curves.
So those are OK.
You do a compression
test, you measure that.
Then, the middle set, you
take, say, for one density,
for one stress
strain curve-- say
that's your curve, the
middle one there, 0.03.
Say you loaded it
up to some point,
or say you looked at some
point here, on the curve.
You would figure
out, for that stress,
what's the area under the
curve up to that stress.
So you'd have a stress and
an area under the curve
up to that stress.
And you could then-- say
we know what this foam is.
It's-- I don't know-- a
polyurethane or something.
So say we know Es.
Then we could divide
those two numbers by Es.
And we would plot
that one thing.
Let me just walk over here.
So this is the 0.03.
So if it's in the
linear elastic reading,
it would be somewhere in here.
Then I would scoot along,
say, to here someplace.
I would do a whole bunch of
points all the way along there.
And at every point, I would
say, what's the stress,
and what's the energy
absorbed up to that stress.
OK?
And then I would plot-- doot,
doot, doot, doot, doot-- up
here, I would plot
all those points.
OK?
And then when I got
to this part here,
that corresponds to
that part over there.
OK?
Are we all good with that?
OK.
So then we repeat-- so we get
one curve on the middle chart.
Then, for the
different densities
and the different
stress strain curves,
we plot a different curve for
each of the different densities
doing the same process.
And the thing we notice
is that these points here
are really the optimum point.
Because at that point there,
you absorb as much energy
as you possibly can
for that stress.
OK?
And we notice, happily,
that those points
lie on a line, basically,
on a straight line.
And we tick of what
the different densities
are-- so 0.01, 0.03, 0.1, 0.3.
OK?
And that line there, and all
of these stress strain curves,
and all these lines here,
curves here, they all
correspond to one strain rate.
All right?
So now I could take that line
there for that first strain
rate, and it would be one
of these thinner lines
here for a particular
strain rate.
And I would mark
off-- just the same
as I've got here, 0.01, 0.03--
I'd go 0.01, 0.03, 0.1, 0.3.
All right?
And then I would repeat
this whole process again
for a different strain rate.
So I'd go back to doing
some mechanical tests
at, now, a new strain rate.
And typically, the
new strain rate
is going to be bigger or
smaller by a factor of 10 or so,
because you're not going to see
much difference in the behavior
unless you get big changes
in the strain rate.
So you're going to change the
strain rate significantly.
You get a new series of
these stress strain curves.
Then you get a
similar-- very similar,
but not quite the same--
series of these curves here.
And what you'd find is
you'd have another line here
that would be offset a
little from the first one.
And the positions of
where these densities were
would also be offset a
little from the first one.
And then you'd draw
the second one.
So the second strain
rate line would go here.
And the little density positions
would be offset a little bit,
and you would mark them off.
And you basically repeat it
for different strain rates,
and then you build
this thing up.
And then the density
lines connect too.
Is that OK?
So that's how you generate that.
So the idea is, this bottom
diagram is really summarizing
all of those shoulder points.
The bottom diagram is really
summarizing all of these points
where the stress
starts to scoot up
at the densification machine.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in
question 3, we were
constructing the graph in the
middle for this particular one.
What confused me is
that on the graph,
the variable on the
x-axis is stress,
whereas in the question,
we were given the stress.
So I drew something that looked
as it should have looked.
And it turned out
to be right, but I'm
very confused as to why.
LORNA GIBSON: OK.
Let me try and get rid of that.
And I'm going to
have to remind myself
what the question is again.
OK.
So we have an open
filled aluminum foam.
I asked you to write
the equations for each
of the different regimes.
And those were straight
out of the notes, I think.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
the three inputs were
different relative densities.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
and then you had
to construct the
energy absorption
curve based on those equations.
And I give you three
relative densities.
So this was my solution.
So all this stuff here, I think,
was straight out of the notes.
So there was the--
oops, let me back up
so we start at the beginning.
So there was the
linear elastic part.
There was the stress plateau.
That was just as it
starts to densify.
And then, there's that
line joining up the points.
So you were OK with all of that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, the only part that
confused me is because once
I simplified-- I inputted all
of what we were given such
that I had equations in
terms of the relative density
so I could just apply it to
the different ones given.
But then I wasn't very sure
how-- because I got constants,
I wasn't really sure how--
the slopes should look like,
because they were constants.
LORNA GIBSON: So
you got-- I'm not
sure what you mean
about you got constants.
So what I did was
I said, well, I
know that the diagram has to
have this basic shape, right?
In the first part here is
where it's linear elastic.
And this part here is
the stress plateau.
And that part there
is the densification.
OK?
And I said, well, if I can
find these two points that
correspond to the change
between the linear elastic part
and the stress plateau and
the point that corresponds
to the stress plateau
and the densification,
then I've got the diagram.
Right?
OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think that--
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, can
I stop talking now?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
if you wanted to--
LORNA GIBSON:
Well, it's for you.
So you're OK?
AUDIENCE: I think.
LORNA GIBSON: You.
AUDIENCE: So what confused
me about this question
was that in order to
find the two points,
you'd need to know the strain
at which that [INAUDIBLE].
So I wasn't sure how you
would find that strain.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, I
think I didn't tell you.
Let's see.
Well, let's see.
Do you have to have the strain?
You have that.
I think if you have-- I think
you don't have to have it
in terms of the strain.
I suppose you could put
it in terms of the strain.
I mean, that would be a
different way to do it.
AUDIENCE: But isn't the
equation for the stress plateau
already in terms of the strain?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, but this
assumes that the stress plateau
is just perfectly flat, right?
So this thing here would be
useful, the strain at which
the plateau starts.
But I think that's
the same as saying--
that's the same point as
saying you're at that point
there, because that's
where the plateau starts.
OK?
So I think there's
different ways
you could try to approach this.
But I think--
let's see, I'm just
trying to remember
what I did here.
Yeah, so what I did
here-- so to get point a,
I said, well, this
is the equation
for the linear
elastic bit, right?
And this is the equation
for the stress plateau.
Where I'm at point a here, this
stress is the stress plateau.
So that's why I've put
sigma star plastic there.
And then I said, this is--
the sigma star plastic is--
and this works out
to some number here,
some number times the relative
density to the 3/2 power.
And then I just made
this little table here,
where I said, OK, these
are the densities I
need to get the curve for.
This is going to
be my sigma star
plastic for those densities.
And from that, then I
can get this column here.
It's basically
just that equation
with this substituted in.
And do you see that that
corresponds to the point a?
So I mean, you could
do it by figuring out
what that strain is
and then figuring out
all the points along that
line up to that strain.
But you don't have
to do it that way.
Do you know what I'm saying?
So you're saying-- if I had-- so
say I have my idealized stress
strain curve like that, right?
You're saying, well, I
had to know that strain
there so that I know
where this stops, right?
And I'm saying that
corres-- and you could do it
this way if you wanted to.
You could say that this
is the energy absorbed up
to that point.
And if you know that
the modulus goes
as the relative density
squared times Es,
and you know this, if you
know those two things,
you can figure out
what that strain is.
So you could do it that
way if you wanted to,
but I just did it a
slightly different way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I don't
understand how you just
were able to get rid of
the epsilon minus epsilon
on that curve.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, let's see.
So I think, in the first part,
where it's linear elastic,
I just go up to
epsilon 0, right?
So this part here doesn't
really involve the epsilon,
because I've gotten
rid of it by taking
the square of the stress.
And then here, the other
point I'm looking at
is this point here.
And I've assumed that epsilon 0
is much smaller than epsilon d,
and I've ignored it.
And that's, I think, how I did
it in the notes in the class.
OK?
So when you get to
that point, this strain
here is usually a
few percent at most.
And this strain here is
typically 80% or 90%.
So it's pretty
common to do that.
OK?
Other questions?
So don't forget, the
test covers everything
from the thermal
conductivity of the foams,
it covers the stuff on
trabecular bone, sandwich
panels, and then, the
energy absorption stuff.
Yeah?
Are you a little
exhausted already?
Yeah.
So I'm guessing that this
week and next week, you
have everything due.
You have papers, and
projects, and tests.
Do you have very many exams
left, like final exams?
Yeah, you've got finals?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Oh.
All right.
Anybody else have any questions?
Because I think we can
just go and do other things
if nobody has any
other questions.
So the test is on-- so let's
just review where we're
at for the rest of the term.
So the test's on Wednesday.
And you can bring
one cheat sheet,
but I am not giving
you all those equations
with honey combs and foams.
So I think, on your
cheat sheet, you
would want to put Young's
modulus of an open-celled foam,
shear modulus of an
open-celled foam,
compressive strength
of an open-celled foam,
shear strength of
an open-celled foam.
But I don't think there's going
to be anything more complicated
than that.
And Monday, I was
going to do the
how I became a professor talk.
So if you've seen it and you
don't want to see it again,
you're welcome to not come.
But for you guys, I just
talk about how I got here.
And it's about my life.
It's not about cellular
solids or anything.
And I don't know,
you guys liked it.
You like it, don't you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So if you want to
come, I'll do that.
And then Wednesday,
I thought, I just
need to collect the projects.
I wasn't going to do
anything on Wednesday.
And so I've been
thinking about the
how I became a professor talk.
And I think-- so I have
this idea that students
would like to hear more of
these talks from other faculty.
Would that be true?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LORNA GIBSON: Ah.
Because I've been in touch
with Cindy Barnhart, and we're
going to try and organize
something for the fall.
So I'm going to approach
some other professors--
not just in our department,
across all of MIT--
and see if I can get
other people to do the
how I became a professor talk.
So you would like that?
OK, yeah.
So we'll see if we
can make that happen.